foreign
[Music]
let's imagine the Cold War went another
way
after the Nazis surrendered
Soviet Union flexed its muscles and
asserted its Imperial might
from Tokyo to Tacoma
[Music]
memorials to the Fatherland popped up
around the globe
this would be the Washington Monument
this could have been your morning
commute
[Music]
and now let's fast forward
these were the first semiconductors
this is your keyboard
this was the first IBM computer
this is Facebook headquarters
this is Silicon Valley
well
that didn't happen
but in modern Russia it's easy to get
confused with an extra helping of
spycraft Technology here developed a
world apart from Silicon Valley
and that didn't change when the Soviet
Union collapsed
[Music]
[Applause]
the Moscow over the past decade the
tsar's Gilded churches and monuments to
the proletariat have given way to the
symbols of modern Russia
[Music]
opulent capitalist towers that poke
through the clouds
[Music]
this is where I met Dmitry Grisham hello
Dimitri he's the co-founder of mail
route group and one of only a few people
east of Helsinki who can drive me to the
office in his own Tesla
I organize the drive for all my
employees like 3 000 people
because they want all to test how
accelerate
E3 sits atop a Russian Tech Empire and
runs an investment fund for robotics
with its roots in Silicon Valley that
doesn't make you want to move there you
have so much going on here maybe one day
never say never right
[Music]
Dimitri's tried to copy Silicon Valley
culture here in Moscow we're Mail Route
group operates two instant messaging
networks a search engine a price
comparison website and a ton of online
games
control the three largest Russian social
networking sites the biggest one is VK
the Facebook knockoff
Dimitri and mailroot group took over VK
in 2014 after its founder Pavel durov
refused to reveal information about
Ukrainian activists to the Kremlin
after I've lost his company and now
lives in self-imposed Exile overall then
do you consider the Russian texian
competitive yes and you know it's
interesting things that it's very few
countries where local players are very
strong and comparing for example with
China this internet is fully closed we
have a Facebook Instagram all kind of
Western players and still uh pretty
successful so I think we have pretty
pretty tough competition
to get a taste of the high life of a
tech oligarch
foreign
and I headed for a bite to eat at the
tallest restaurant in Europe
354 meters above the Moscow traffic
Dimitri grew up programming on computers
that plugged into Soviet TVs
of when he enrolled at Moscow State
Technical University in 1995. in the
same year Microsoft announce Windows 95
this famous song from Rolling Stone
started me up
[Music]
next two years I tried to write my own
windows
so expensive Windows maybe you can just
make it right cheap cheap version this
is a sitting writing it but after some
time I say okay no it's too hard
[Music]
he might have failed to rewrite the
world's most popular operating system
but
he did stumble on the copycat business
model
the became male root group
[Music]
it's hard to imagine now but in 2004
only nine percent of Russians had
internet access what was the Russian
government's assessment of the
technology industry they didn't know
that they exist
that all changed in 2012.
just internet Market in Europe
ain't about Putin an organized protests
against his re-election
the Kremlin responded in full orwellian
Glory
with a series of laws that allows them
to flag opposition sites as extremists
and Blacklist them ever since it's been
hard to tell where the Vlad web begins
and ends I think in the U.S the idea is
that the Russian government and the tech
companies are just intertwined if you
follow the law you are key definitely
the laws became more complicated right
and sometimes this definitely the way
how to interpret the law
demand all sides Russians can access
move their servers here including the
Googles and Facebooks of the world once
on Russian soil they have to store six
months worth of data about people's
Every Move online
and then give the Kremlin access Russian
companies like Mail Route protested they
said these measures would take a
ridiculous amount of storage space
but they obviously lost
American companies have said there's no
way they're moving to Russia so now
they're criminal Enterprises here and
that's how you build a sovereign
internet
when we grow our business how concept
was that internet was a global system no
border at all use it everywhere can
connect to everywhere data can be
migrated everything so it really was a
global phenomena but now I think that
fundamental Global shift everywhere that
you have country you have borders and
inside these borders you have different
kind of rules how data is moving how
connectivity is moving who can connect
to what who can do what so
we're not having like Global Internet
we're having some kind of some Global
Internet
but a lot of like local internets and
for me this is big Set uh it jumps a
change
foreign
it's hard to wrap your head around just
how big Siberia is
and even harder to understand how most
people live here
so to get acquainted I found another
Dimitri this one a real natural born
Siberian man to initiate me into the
ways of the Russian wilderness
perfect idea
a trip to the Banya is an ancient and
some would say masochistic Russian
bonding ritual it consists of three
delightful steps okay Ashley Inferno is
a ready for entrance step one nearly
have heat stroke
step two shrinkage
[Music]
step three get wet
what does this do keep silent please
[Music]
when he's not beating other men with
Birch branches my new Russian friend
Dimitri is a philosophy Professor here
an academic
destination
Small Town hours by plane from Moscow in
about 30 minutes outside Russia's third
largest city Nova sabirsk thank you
Nikita khrushchev's government declared
60 years ago that this would be the
Siberian home of the Soviet Academy of
Sciences
of a remote tiger forest that stretches
halfway around the planet
it was the first Soviet technopolis and
it was a good opportunity for many young
scientists how has it changed over the
last 40 years in comparison to Soviet
time
we have not so much opportunities but we
love our place because it's wonderful
the 40 institutes a real scientific
community
what will the test here no Beauty to the
enemies of science cheers
[Music]
soaked swatted steaming and having
proven my loyalty to science I was ready
to explore academic
[Music]
here the Soviets hid temples to science
in the trees was shrines to match like
this one to all the mice they sacrificed
on the altar of genetic research
inside the Nuclear Physics Institute it
feels like I walked under the set of
doctor Strangelove
these analog tiles laser Contraptions
and miles of metal pipes were all built
to push nuclear science to its Summit
replicating the sun's Power by Smashing
atoms together
people have been chasing Fusion for
decades what's still encouraging and
exciting about this field it's a
scientific problem is like a huge
mountain and for 60 years people are
trying to get to the top everything
around the base of the mountain is like
a trash dump
the bodies and stuff but you can imagine
the results you can achieve when you get
to the top
Professor Alexei Beck lumischev
researches something called open trap
mechanisms to encourage Fusion this is
also useful in order to make plasma
thrusters for space ships
at the moment it is just an idea
the Soviet government attracted
Brilliant Minds like Alexis to Siberia
with spacious apartments in the kind of
prestige they could only get in a town
founded as a utopian nerdocracy
foreign
[Applause]
Union fell so did the walls keeping
scientists here
and many of them bolted to work at IBM
or MIT or Boeing
for those who stayed the Utopia has lost
its luster
over time the difference in Pay between
scientists and say bus drivers went in
favor of bus drivers okay if you are
overworked and without pay you you want
to go elsewhere
ten years ago the Russian government
decided it needed to hit Refresh on the
entire town to pull Siberian science out
of its post-soviet slump
they're turning to a new generation of
Engineers plucked from the tiger to lead
the way and one of the most successful
so far is Dimitri tribitsu yes another
Dimitri today
is changing now there are not only
scientists but there are also a lot of
companies more like startups yeah more
like startups
today Dimitri's the poster boy for a
Siberian startup success story
[Music]
on started off making king-size air
filters for hospitals and other
businesses and now they have their eyes
on China
's success belongs to Dimitri but it's
built on a blueprint drawn up by the
Russian government
his headquarters is on a sprawling
government-funded campus called academ
park with this crazy Tower in the middle
of it
not recommended if you have a fear of
heights
the place is a prime example of one of
the big ideas in Russian Tech a cradle
to grave genius Factory
[Music]
across the country they start them young
with a strictly uniform education heavy
on math and science
they pull the best out of Siberia and
send them down the street to Nova sabir
State University from there they used to
funnel their brains to places like the
nuclear Institute but now that that's a
bit retro many of them end up here in
the tech Tower
here it's like someone visited a few
Silicon Valley startups punched the copy
button ran it through Google translate
and then hit paste in the middle of
Siberia here's the living wall only here
it's dead here's the maker space and the
3D printed Putin
here's the gym only it's Siberia so it
comes with bear
[Music]
[Applause]
hello innovation
[Music]
over the past few years Russia has honed
the art of turning computer science
nerds into AI building geniuses
to test one of the most powerful and
controversial pieces of AI infused
software ever built I've traveled to the
heart of Moscow and its famed Gorky Park
[Music]
just five years ago this was a decaying
Soviet Relic
it's buzzing with people on wheels
a friendly Russian faces
[Music]
and my goal here is to find a few
hi would you mind if I take a photo of
your face who I'm trying to do a little
bit of an experiment can I take a photo
of your face
I just take a photo of you and then you
see we see if it can find your VK
perfect you might find me on Facebook it
doesn't work on Facebook yet because
they don't let you search the database
find face is an Android app that lets
you take a picture of a new friend
or a complete stranger in a few seconds
it scans all 250 million photos from VK
the Russian Facebook clock off and then
finds a match
all right let's see what happens Moment
of Truth here we go
oh it's me it's Destiny oh it's me yes
it's me and your hair is so different in
my photo
definitely find me at first yeah so it
works yeah it's really cool do you think
it's strange it's strange but cool you
like some girl and you take a photo and
you can find her and text her or
something yeah so you you guys like it
so if I forgot if this is my son or not
I can be check it with my phone okay
[Music]
this year fine face tickets algorithm to
America
for something called the mega face
challenge
there be Google and a lot of other face
spotting software
to find out how they did it nice to meet
you nice to meet you I went to meet the
algorithm's Creator at the office of his
company and Tech do you mind showing me
how the technology Works a little bit
yeah can we try me
so these are my Russian Brethren my
cousins
is it ranked in order by who they think
looks the most like this
this is like a 60 year old with a
machine gun
another guy with a gun I want to show
you something else
why am I a bear
so the similarity is very low but yeah
so but it seems that there are some some
similarity
sometimes it's difficult to say why
neural network works this way but but it
works
RTM programmed a neural network that
approaches face finding differently than
others
thousands of image matches and after
about six months of training training
voila it learned to read faces
essentially you don't even know what the
neural network is seeing in the
beginning a metal Network gives a random
answers and the accuracy is close to
zero and during training if everything
goes well the accuracy grows if you can
efficiently find the exact person among
huge data sets it opens a lot more
interesting use cases like for example
you can search for criminals in real
life among all the strip cameras in the
city
are we creeped out yet
maybe we should be
entech has already signed a contract
with the Moscow City police though archa
won't talk about it and he says they
already have agreements with other law
enforcement agencies both inside and
outside Russia
it's easy to imagine what the FBI or its
Russian counterpart the FSB could do
with this kind of Technology
so it's a little bit controversial right
because anyone can identify you now out
of the crowd I would say that the
implications of this very
scary I think f is bear is searching us
right there I'm not I'm saying like
companies here are big companies
corporations and governments definitely
know everything about you but
for random people this makes us much
easier you have to be careful if you go
it outside in the street or in a
Facebook or any other social network
you've done it yeah you're open to to be
recognized
[Music]
this idea that you're not Anonymous when
you walk the street anymore somebody can
just snap your photo and identify who
you are you must have thought about that
when you were developing the technology
when we were developing we were thinking
only about accuracy and how how cool it
is but if I wish it finished when you
have uh smartphones with you because
they can track all the information about
you
it's a battle between technology and
privacy
my personal guess that technology will
win
[Music]
on the outskirts of Moscow you'll find
skokova
where the hope is that other startups
like fine face will come to life
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
is that people love to float
[Music]
and there's no better place to float
than here at the Dead Sea in Israel
where without any effort at all large
mammals can achieve buoyancy
there's some ritual involved to doing
this place the right way
you need to fall into some mud lather up
and then relax with a good read sorry to
do that to your white shirt Jack you
handsome devil
Israel has many wonderful sides
this is one of its finest
Arabs Jews tourists and TV hosts all
come here
[Music]
but float together for a while
[Laughter]
it's unfettered
or at least less fettered Joy
[Music]
foreign
could remain so simple
but it can't
to come to Israel is to witness the
fierce tensions that Loom over this
country firsthand
it's spy balloons floating by highways
it's walled off and fenced in Arab
cities
[Music]
and tourist spots turn quiet due to the
stabbings and random acts of violence
that have become so prevalent over the
past two years
foreign
to the Israeli technology industry
[Applause]
the Israeli military dominates much of
this country's culture
at 18 years of age men and women head
off for two to three years of required
service
kids who would be trying to locate the
best kegger are sleeping through class
in the United States find themselves
here dealing with the most intensive
situations
[Music]
[Applause]
these young soldiers in the Israeli
Defense Forces or IDF also learn to use
some of the most advanced military
technology around
how the IDF has given Israel a unique
Tech Edge I decided to check it out up
close
to see the Iron Dome
I've traveled to Ashkelon
the coastal city just south of Tel Aviv
that nudges up against the Gaza Strip
what we're seeing here right now is the
launcher
this launcher has 20 missiles on it you
can see uh the red light flashing which
means it's armed and ready
[Music]
here one of the dozen or so Iron Dome
batteries sits at the ready to intercept
missiles and provide Israel with a type
of shield from aerial attacks the Iron
Dome Commander Lieutenant Colonel Iran
Cohen oversees its operation is this as
close as we get or do we get uh this is
as close as we get
[Music]
three years and about 200 million
dollars to develop this defense system
it relies on a radar that instantly
detects when a missile has been fired
algorithms quickly try to determine what
type of projectile is in the air and
whether it's heading for a populated or
strategic area
so Iron Dome launches a missile of its
own
said that Iron Dome has taken down more
than 1 000 missiles since it turned on
in 2011.
90 success rate
some people question the accuracy of
these figures what's clear though is
that the algorithms capable of directing
projectiles while performing a
cost-benefit analysis on human life are
among the most advanced in the world
foreign
this network of launchers is highly
mobile and constantly on the move
this site like many is temporary
everything you see here can be moved out
in a matter of hours and we move around
a lot to make sure nobody knows where we
are all the time
unless you live here it's difficult to
imagine just how much this technology
has transformed the lives of ordinary
Israelis I can tell you from my own
personal experience sitting in my own
house and seeing Rockets fire towards my
house and operating this is an
incredible system and succeeding we
already doing when you see your house
that you're protecting and your family
and your friends and your soldiers it's
a sense of
great uh sense of pride
for many Palestinians Iron Dome means
something else
that's the most visible part of an
expansive Israeli security apparatus
that includes drones
checkpoints and Espionage technology
those tools have been put to immediate
use in the West Bank Gaza and throughout
Israel
terrorist bombings have declined
missiles have met their match
but lower Tech forms of protest like
stabbings are now on the rise
what's been remarkable is the speed at
which young Israelis take these types of
high-tech tools
and then privatize them once they leave
the Army be it be at this time or War
Israeli Innovations pop up throughout
the world
[Music]
I forget dull strip malls and office
parts
startups of Tel Aviv come to life here
in the city's vibrant neighborhoods they
feed off the city's energy and the
employees have a chance to escape their
cubicles and live a little
I came here to meet one of the people
that shaped the Israeli startup
lifestyle
[__] Kramer served in the IDF almost
25 years ago and his first company
checkpoint invented the freaking
firewall
we always had the starter box so we
always talked about stuff that we will
do afterwards and it was always around
startups
like a lot of Israel's tackle it [__]
got his start with unit 8200 a top
branch of the IDF group 8200 right is
this is this famous part of the IDF that
I guess equivalent to the NSA in the
United States which was like the bedok
of everything else that I've done
afterwards was it 22 23 year old I was
ahead of a unit you know of 20 people
you know very high responsibility you
know I was you know making decisions in
millions of dollars and
the IDF functions sort of like a
never-ending networking event the first
question at a cocktail party is what
unit you served in for members of unit
8200 these ties have led to Israel
dominating the market for security
software and Hardware what makes Israel
so well suited to to startups and
Technology there's always an infusion of
new talents
form the IDF and the infusion of talent
you've got the recipe for a successful
startup Nation yeah [__] has invested
in dozens of Israeli companies
[Applause]
[Music]
the extreme end of what the IDF can
Inspire have gone to herzelia
small Beach town and Tech Hub that
brushes right up against Tel Aviv
it's here that a company called
spacepharma has set out to make some
Interstellar drugs
[Music]
if Humanity would like to move out of
Earth they must learn the microgravity
conditions in order to survive on the
way to Mars and to other places Florida
CEO Yosi Yamin used to head up the IDF
satellite program then he and his
comrades hit on a big possibly
profitable idea
they assembled some space software and
science experts and set to work trying
to make life easier on astronauts we cut
the middlemen the astronaut is not a
scientist you need to survive you need
to eat you need to train you need to
sleep he cannot do too much science
space Pharma has built a shoebox size
laboratory that will hitch rides into
orbit on Rockets from companies like
SpaceX the goal is to shrink down
state-of-the-art scientific equipment
and automate how it runs experiments
this would allow a great deal more
science to take place on the
International Space Station
so we're going to go in the labs okay
thank you for the booties you're very
welcome
so it's a pretty small bio lab but the
equipment's big and this you can't bring
to space so the whole idea of what we're
trying to do and what we're really going
to look at is how we take this equipment
and bring it down to the small scale
a typical laboratory has
refrigerator-sized machines microscopes
pipettes and a host of liquids and
chemicals it's a very manual messy
process that's tough enough to pull off
here on Earth we just looked at all that
large equipment this is what we fit in
the ISS has already led to the
development of new drugs and insights
about organisms
molecules floating about freely in
Solutions can behave more naturally than
when they're smeared flat on a petri
dish every
dominated by this lens of gravity what
goes up must come down we remove that
lens of gravity and we learn something
new
spacepharma wants to use its machines to
let companies and researchers conduct
dozens of different kinds of experiments
and to see what space can teach us
to pull myself out of the clouds and
learn more about Israel's startup
culture I went for a walk on the beach
back in Tel Aviv with another local Tech
Legend
thank you very much armed with a law
degree and an MBA ADI sopher Tani had
led a number of young companies and help
spur on Israel's technology economy 50s
now she runs Facebook's Israel
operations
by the way
Ops except the US yes okay it's not even
close 1 400 new startups in 2015. 1400
new startups
[Music]
women must serve alongside man in the
military here
once hope to fly Jets but because of the
gender restrictions at the time she
ended up evaluating who could become a
pilot
she sees the time in the Air Force as
crucial to her career what's the
uniqueness of the female experience in
Israel because of the military service
it must have some long-term effects yeah
I absolutely think it does women in
Israel
probably start their career life with
more confidence with the feeling that
they also can but are we done in Israel
in terms of women taking part no we will
not and and I think that in Israel we
are probably because of the military
because of startup Nation because of the
culture I think that we are probably
closer to achieve that but we are
definitely still not there
foreign
after our chat the D insisted that I go
Revel in Tel aviv's famous nightlife
Tel Aviv stands out as one of the great
surprises of my travels people head out
late here often starting dinner at 9pm
the bartenders look for any excuse to do
shots with their patrons and their
patrons or at least this Patron look for
any excuse to oblige the
The Old City the boardwalk Joy rides
this is a wondrous place that feels at
times as if it exists within its own
bubble separate from the rest of the
country
[Music]
from the Cosmopolitan Coast I climbed
the winding Mountain Road to Jerusalem
Tel Aviv may be the Beating Heart of the
Israeli Tech world but most Jews
consider Jerusalem to be the country's
soul
foreign
you know what they say about the soul
if you think about it the most basic
thing of human communication is is eye
contact
by the device seeing you you get a whole
nother world of interaction the window
to the soul the window exactly the
window to the solar the window to the
brain
look around look to the right look to
the left UT kampinski is the co-founder
and CEO of umove based here in Jerusalem
the company has developed a way to
replace eye tracking gear that usually
costs tens of thousands of dollars with
algorithms they can run on an iPad or
smartphone it's a little disorienting at
first to try and play a video game just
by moving your head
foreign
movement eye movement Iris movement
blinks and then and then an analysis of
that Kempinski hopes the technology will
give us New Rapid insights into
conditions like concussions
[Music]
so this is like when they Shine the
white light that you have to follow I
mean you see doctors doing that right
exactly and then based on the score we
can tell if I have a concussion and I
don't you don't have one I don't have a
concussion
[Music]
thinks that these hard science
applications with real world uses
distinguish Israel's Tech scene
especially for Jerusalem startups people
are looking for you know real deep Tech
I can't say I'm you know making an app
for taking pictures of food you have to
give a you know a real explanation to
your uh Jewish grandmother about what
what is that for
[Music]
this is the Damascus gate
it's not that far at all from where we
were earlier today
there's a sniper up in the window who's
guarding against a lot of the recent
stabbings that have been going on
Jerusalem is trying to turn into a
Technology city and this is the reality
of how these businesses have to come to
life in this type of environment
the moment you step into Jerusalem it's
clear that the city carries with it the
weight of thousands of years of History
everyone in the Middle East and by
extension the world has their eyes fixed
here
on Alexa mosque on the Wailing Wall
on the spot where it's believed Jesus
was crucified
[Music]
it was a small spot of land with
outsized global importance
no no under heavy guard
carved into minute slices and fortified
with walls
[Music]
[Applause]
those barriers went up to curb violence
based on Ancient disputes
seen another way they've become
blockades
that hold back modern opportunity
[Music]
foreign North
from Jerusalem to Nazareth
the largest Arab Enclave in Israel
place with a laid-back Vibe and a very
specific flavor
we can see a 10 or 15 places just for
shawarma
so because of that I call it Valley
Shawarma Valley you have the Silicon
Valley we have the Shawarma Valley as we
are at the middle of the Shawarma Valley
that's fari Sudan he opened Israel's
first Arab Tech accelerator and he knows
everyone in town
Arabs do not have to serve in the
military and lack the tech connections
supplied by the IDF
Fadi is set to work trying to fix this
and to help Arab Engineers benefit from
Israel's Tech boom
in a controversial move he's linking
them up with the tech Moguls who have
come out of the idf's unit 8200
security and Espionage folks
anyone is going out of the 200 first
thing is thinking about this to make a
startup
that undergraduates have a special NGO
that help them
at our community it's not so popular to
have stuff up because it's a new
industry it's very risky
is a rebel okay he was the only Arab in
his class at the technion Israel's Elite
Technical University
inside of this building he shepherded
dozens of like-minded Engineers
they're building software consumer
services and Hardware in an effort to
make sure that the Arab speaking world
has the latest and greatest technology I
think if we can be part of the ecosystem
in Tel Aviv and to be part of the star
technician we can raise the standard of
life of the Arab Community here because
Israel is known as this startup Nation
but it's left out a big chunk of people
so exactly there's two communities and
the Jewish Orthodox the government now
is putting some money to find the ways
how to engage them with a startup Nation
here because they believe that if we are
not part of that the startup Nation will
be somehow slowed here and it cannot
continue to be the second place after
the Silicon Valley
a handful of his companies have already
taken off and made Headway in billion
dollar Industries but it's proven tough
for them to find investment dollars
there's a clear bias against Arab
companies and many of their backers have
opted to remain anonymous or to funnel
their Investments through offshore
accounts
but fatty remains optimistic I hope in
the coming years maybe we have big
success stories let's say the first
unicorn startup from the Arab community
may be here in Israel so this may began
attract more and more entrepreneurs to
be part of that and like other
businessmen to be part of this industry
foreign
[Music]
came to an end
it's understandable that tourists have
made fewer visits here in recent months
that the markets have grown quieter
and the mood in the streets more tense
this place can seem daunting from afar
to visit Israel though is to experience
the extraordinary thank you
so many parts of our nature
Joy
conflict
conformity
and Imagination
swirl around together in confounding and
inspiring ways
I'm not sure that anyone will really
ever make sense of all this
but it's spectacular to witness and feel
even if just for a short while
foreign
[Music]
if you're having tea with a giant Hello
Kitty doll
then you're almost certainly
in Japan
[Music]
this is a place that specializes
in obsessing over things
and taking every want and need to their
unnatural extreme
if you desire a refreshing drink
there's a vending machine that will
evaluate your face and pick the perfect
beverage or
[Music]
perhaps you prefer to imbibe while in
the company of an ornamental owl
whoa oh sh or to down a latte with a
three-dimensional robot as garnish
[Music]
Ah that's a good robot
the Japanese of course also fetishize
technology like no other culture
[Music]
Japan's once glorious Tech shine may
have dulled with the decline of Sony and
other Empires
but without question there's a new tech
movement on the rise
would I begin my journey but in Tokyo
[Music]
way around the city in an orderly
fashion
doing their best not to bother anyone
the hustle of Modern Life dominates the
city
[Music]
comes to life
welcome to the Robot Restaurant
[Applause]
[Music]
this touristy and insane as all of this
is it actually gets to the heart of
Japan's relationship with robots
the machines here come with stories and
personality they're good they're bad and
sometimes they eat people
but far away from the fire-breathing
dinosaurs and werewolf guitarists
researchers at a Tokyo Museum have set
up a workshop where they're looking to
prove that robots can be imbued with
life hello Ashley eat your red pill and
try to keep up
foreign
[Music]
has helped create this thing
which looks like it comes straight from
ex machina Central Casting
through a series of sensors and
artificial intelligence software
this Android looks out into the world
and reacts to what it sees
[Music]
the Android is in effect evolving based
on what its AI software seems to like
basically there are two different
mechanisms one is autonomous or Rhythm
generators okay it's coupled with each
other also there's artificial neural
networks spontaneously firing and
sending signals to each other
[Music]
someone approaches the Android the
sensors detect the movement
[Music]
and then the software kicks in to
determine how the robot will move in
response
[Music]
but for the moment it has a movement
style that could be described as that
really drunk guy at the party okay so in
each one of these sensor boxes right
here yes there's two cameras yep and
this is measuring the distance yes so
when I
come closer or further away from the
machine then robot has to do something
it has to react to that yeah you guys
will add more and more sensors yeah we
can put like a temperature sensors sound
sensors many other sensors
[Music]
armed with more sensors the robot can
make more judgments about its
environment and more nuanced reactions
over time the movements and gurgles
change
the thinking is that the robot will
eventually form its own personality and
possibly even language
what's the deal with the noise is it
hungry
this sound is designed by my students
and behavior is modifying those sounds
the sound is changing all the time
like you know A Primitive language
that's I think the interesting part of
it like our babies we don't have to tell
everything to the baby but baby can
learn unconsciously by interacting with
people just with the environment right
[Music]
once we have a bunch of lifelike systems
around us maybe our concept of what is
life will be very much different
and then if we want to coexist with
robots then we maybe have to learn
different languages they have different
way of thinking
[Music]
so that doesn't freak you out you think
that's well that's I think it's much
more ideal to me comparing with this you
know very violent world right now
[Music]
well thank you for letting me see your
Android thank you
thank you
oh she said something
I think he said he likes you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
if you want to learn about robot culture
Kyoto is as good of a place to start as
any
[Applause]
for hundreds of years it has been the
Showcase City for Japan's most famous
traditions
from geishas to spectacular temples
over in the University District you can
also find some of Japan's best
technological Minds I've come to
dashisha University to dive deep into
Japan's love affair with robots with a
professor and one of Japan's most active
robot hobbyists
foreign
[Music]
wow
yeah Akira's got good news
Takashi hori nouchi embodies a Japanese
concept known as otaku it refers to a
person who obsesses over something be it
Hello Kitty sushi for robots
for Takashi robotics is more than a
hobby it's his passion most of his free
time goes into assembling these things
by hand out of 3D printed body parts and
electronics do you work on these almost
every day yes about two hours almost
every day
that's cool
each one takes months to build including
the software for the choreographed moves
but it's not all for show these robots
must fight to earn their key Akira would
hit other robots yeah
one of takashi's robots recently took
first place in a competition making him
King of the otaku
and when you're the king there are
people that want to study you
one of Japan's foremost researchers into
the relationship between man and Bots is
hirofumi katsuno an anthropologist here
at toshisha University I was looking for
you know that the passionate people who
work on robots I joined the group and
started to create my own robots and
YouTube met at least
hero felt compelled to ask that Seinfeld
in question what's the deal with Japan
and all those robots foreign
National Quest
to establish its own identity and after
the World War II
so after the sort of Devastation of the
whole land Japan started to rebuild the
nation through promoting the peaceful
use of Science and Technology
in that process I think many anime
creators and manga creators started to
ponder the kind of Ideal relationship
between the Japanese and Technology
who is a creator of Astro Boy
hero is not alone and pointing to the
significance of Astro Boy the manga
series started in the 1950s and has a
mad scientist type building an Android
to replace his dead son
The Saga goes on to explore what life
would be like if humans and robots
coexist
and it's that very same idea that one
local Tech Giant has invested millions
of dollars to pursue
Hitachi produces a shocking amount of
stuff from brain scanners right on up to
nuclear reactors
this being Japan it's also in the robot
game
I've gone to one of the company's
vaunted research labs to see its latest
take on the robot that people desire
most an autonomous helper
Hitachi calls this creature emu
hi emu
okay
[Music]
emu was developed as a sort of friendly
robot concierge the equipped with AI for
navigation and speech recognition he
might provide directions at an airport
or do some low-level security work
or he might be kicked over by a cynical
reporter looking for a good time
that's pretty cool
that resemblance between
Hello Kitty is on purpose emu's designer
ASI Baba wanted the robot to have the
same harmless non-creepy feel
is it meant to look like a child yes
because everyone
like it Everyone likes the child yeah
fair enough
there's an adorable quality to these
robots and they may be helpful one day
[Music]
for the moment though
mumbling around
with the extents of what they can do and
they're super expensive to make you have
a price that you're aiming to get to we
will try to you know cheapathan
be cheaper than a car come okay
what's that emu you want to make up for
your failings by showing me an
autonomous vehicle okay
thanks CBU
here's my ride
this sweet hog with the flip top door is
called ropes
away we go
sort of like a self-driving car but it's
meant to travel down sidewalks instead
of on the road
and this is the vehicle's inventor ryoki
hitchinosi
Japan's aging population has forced the
country to try and invent new ways to
help seniors make their way around
cities
the idea here is that someone can summon
the car to their house and then go for a
leisurely drive to the store
the open windows in slow speed of ropets
means that the driver can even have a
chat with a friend
or perhaps an enemy
[Applause]
it's a beautiful utopian future Hitachi
is imagining for us all full of smart
compassionate robots attending to our
every need
but suffice it to say that future very
much Remains the future
the wall the wall the wall
where are we going
where are we going what's going on
helping you
Japan's creative thinking has stalled in
recent years as its Tech Giants and
startups have struggled
[Music]
to find out why I joined my friend
noriaki okubo back in Tokyo for a chat
about Japan's Tech scene over noodles
Aki is a well-connected tech Guru
venture capitalist and Champion noodle
slurper
I've never worked on my slurp technique
after a week in Japan I had so many
questions for him how would you compare
the Japanese VC scene to say Silicon
Valley traditional VCS are really bad
because they don't want to take risks
there's a lot of new VCS that are doing
pretty well new internet companies and
you know they can take risks but not the
traditional you know salary man type VC
yeah
[Music]
wanaki says salary man he's talking
about that image we have of the
conservative heart working Japanese
businessman
this culture rewards Conformity and safe
business decisions
[Music]
lucky it's a key factor in the fall of
Japan's Tech dominance in favor of the
disruptive mentality of Silicon Valley
the decisions that come up from that
kind of process is always going to be
you know let's just do something that's
okay and nothing cool yeah is there a
big call to change the way of thinking I
mean I think there is but it's just
still very the minority yeah
while Aki's take on technology here
holds true in the big picture
there are plenty of people in companies
that see themselves as Rebels trying to
Buck the system
and no one exemplifies this better than
toshiyuki onoko and his company team lab
for anoko inspiration struck when he was
just eight years old
in my second year of Junior High I
usually tell people that an electric
wave struck me I'm not sure what it
actually was or even how to describe
this but a strong sense of Duty that I
needed to do something that had meaning
in society suddenly came over me
if that red pill is still circulating
through your system then this will feel
perfect
let's see if we can go find a fish
[Music]
it's one of Team lab's world famous
techno art experiences
mapping technology to track the fish
when they hit somebody's body
you're supposed to turn into a flower
supposed to move on
let's go down there hallway
how long does it take to do one of these
projects
forever we take one idea and create
reconsider then repeat the process
[Music]
for example the exhibit you saw Crystal
Universe we've been working on for five
years
the pool one we've been working on for
two to three years
teamlab has around 400 employees
ever weirder things
and working in their makeshift
Laboratories what's this one baby
you're making clothes right I think it's
for a show it's for a dancer no he's
making clothes for a mascot uh here
we're experimenting with a device that
allows you to manipulate waves in the
water you're gonna make patterns in the
water and control the patterns yeah
that's cool
this is the sort of inoku is known
throughout Japan as a flamboyant
character
for him you either create something new
or you grow old and stay quiet
Japanese Society has aged too much it is
a society of old people it's
conservative and it can't seek value in
new things
so you're trying to change that no no no
no no no no no no no no no I want to be
with people who want to take a step into
the new world
people who are creative who want to
change the world these people I hope to
inspire to have an influence on them or
by having them experience our art I want
to shake their values so rather than
taking on people who don't want change I
work to inspire people who want to
change
[Music]
it's a no-go and the people wired like
him the two seem to be Japan's best hope
for a major technology resurgence
the well-funded robotics labs and
corporate Giants do amazing research but
they've struggled to keep Pace with
places like Silicon Valley and China
when it comes to making products that
actually reach consumers
Japan remains trapped between two worlds
the old
and the new
it's a country that has turned the
future into a religion but that must
still deal with an aging population and
rigid Customs the way forward for Japan
its chance to really make a Mark will
come from its robots
emu for one is already getting ready to
be a guide and chauffeur at the 2020
Olympics
yeah
for now I say goodnight to Japan
may all our dreams be filled with Hello
Kitty
[Music]